>> Larry: I WANT ONE
MORE QUESTION BECAUSE THIS IS
FOR ME AT @MRNEWKLUTE.
HE SAID IS IT ODD THAT A FEW
WEEKS AFTER YOU MOVE INTO THE
NEIGHBORHOOD, JON STEWART
DECIDES HE WANTS TO MOVE OUT?
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
I WOULD SAY THAT YES, IT IS ODD.
I'VE SAID ALL ALONG THAT JON IS
A RACIST.
( LAUGHTER )
PEOPLE NEVER BELIEVE ME.
NOW THEY HAVE THE EVIDENCE.
I CAN'T MAKE HIM STAY, BUT, HEY,
YOU KNOW, JON, WHATEVER.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT IT.
OKAY.
REMEMBER, WE ACTUALLY WORKED IN
THE CBS BUILDING WITH JOHN
OLIVER.
>> THIS IS A TRUE STORY.
WE WORKED-- BEFORE WE MOVED INTO
THIS BUILDING, WE WORKED ON THE
SAME FLOOR AS JOHN OLIVER, AND
RIGHT WHEN THIS SHOW MOVED IN,
THEY PUT UP A BIG SECURITY DOOR.
"THE BLACK SHOW IS IN TOWN."
>> Larry: THEY WERE OUT ON
HIATUS
BUT THAT'S WHAT IT FELT LIKE.
TIME TO GET TO "KEEP IT 100".
IT'S TIME TO GET REAL ON A
PERSONAL LEVEL.
KEEP IT 100.
THERE WE GO.
>> IT'S ACTUALLY A HUNNED
I SAID IT SO MANY TIMES, YOU
HAVE NO IDEA-- IF I SAY KEEP IT
ONE HELP IF I SAID KEEP IT A
HUNDRED, IT'S NO KEEP IT 100.
THAT'S HOW THE TWEETS SOUND.
YOU GUYS DON'T HAVE SOUND ON
YOUR TWEETS.
OKAY, HERE'S ONE.
THIS ONE IS KIND OF
PHILOSOPHICAL WHICH IS KIND OF
COOL.
IT'S ONE I HEARD ON THE RADIO
YEARS AGO.
SO LET'S START WITH RORY ON THIS
ONE.
IF YOUR DOG, WHO YOU LOVE
DEARLY-- AND I KNOW YOUR DOG--
AND A STRANGER WHO YOU DON'T
KNOW ARE DROWNING.
AND YOU ONLY HAVE TIME TO SAVE
ONE, ONCE YOU SAVE ONE, THE
OTHER ONE DIES.
WHICH ONE DO YOU SAVE?
>> IS THIS STRANGER AN ADULT?
>> Larry: WHAT'S HARDER FOR
YOU?
( LAUGHTER ).
>> IF IT'S AN ADULT, I SAVE MY
DOG EVERY TIME.
BECAUSE--
>> WOW!
>> STATISTICALLY SPEAKING MOST
PEOPLE ARE ASS( BLEEP )
IF IT'S A KID, I GO FOR BOTH.
BUT NO, AN ADULT EVERY TIME--
PARKER'S THE BEST DOG IN THE
WORLD.
I'M SORRY.
I'D SAVE MY DOG 100%.
KEEPING IT A HUNNED.
>> DID HE KEEP IT 100?
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ).
>> Larry: OKAY.
MICHAELA, DOG, WHO YOU LOVE
DEARLY, OR A PERSON?
>> I LOVE THAT DOG.
BUT I'M SLIGHTLY ALLERGIC.
>> Larry: OH!
>> I GO WITH THE PERSON.
>> Larry: I LOVE THAT PEOPLE
SAY "OH!"
>> CALL ME A HUMANIST.
I'M GOING WITH THE HUMAN.
>> Larry: I THINK SHE'S
KEEPING IT 100.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> I AM.
>> Larry: ANTHONY, WHAT DO YOU
DO?
YOUR DEAR DOG OR DO YOU SAVE THE
PERSON?
>> WOW.
>> Larry: AND THE PERSON IS A
NETWORK EXECUTIVE.
( LAUGHTER )
>> WHICH NETWORK?
>> Larry: I DON'T KNOW.
>> IF IT'S PAULEY, OR SHERMAN--
WHO?
>> Larry: LET'S NOT MENTION
NAMES.
WE DON'T MENTION NAMES.
>> YOU WANT ME TO KEEP IT A
HUNDRED.
>> Larry: ANTHONY, YOU'RE
TAKING TOO LONG.
>> I'M SAVING THE PERSON.
( BOOING ).
>> ( BLEEP ) YOU!
>> Larry: YOU TOOK TOO LONG.
>> I'M SAVING A HUMAN BEING.
>> Larry: I DON'T BELIEVE
YOU'RE SAVING ANYBODY.
>> ( BLEEP ) THE DOG!
I DON'T EVEN LIKE DOGS!
( BLEEP ).
>> Larry: YOU KNOW WHAT, JUST
FOR THAT LANGUAGE YOU GET
ALL THE TEA. ALRIGHT, S.E., WHAT
DO YOU SAY?
>> I DON'T HAVE A DOG AND I
DON'T LIKE PEOPLE.
SO CAN I JUST GO GET COFFEE
INSTEAD?
CAN I JUST GO HANG OUT.
>> Larry: NO, BUT YOU CAN GET
SOME TEA!
>> I'LL TAKE SOME TEA.
>> Larry: I DON'T BELIEVE
ANYBODY ON THIS PANEL WOULD
SAVE ANYBODY.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.